.
Untertitel: ARD Text (2017)
Der kann was!
Herzlich willkommen
zu Teil 2 von "Chemie in der Küche".
Kurz vor Weihnachten
hatten wir eine Folge
zu der Chemie von Butterplätzchen.
Viele von euch wollten
einen Teil 2 mit Kuchen.
Und das machen wir jetzt.
Wir machen heute
einen Vanille-Buttermilch-Kuchen.
Danach kommt da
noch irgend ein Frosting drauf.
Aber es geht erst mal
um die Base, um den Kuchen.
Eine der wichtigsten Eigenschaften
bei diesem Kuchen
ist seine Fluffigkeit,
nenne ich es mal.
Das heißt, da soll
möglichst viel Luft drin sein.
Und es soll nicht zäh sein,
wie jetzt ein Brot.
Es soll auch nicht
so dicht sein wie ein Brownie.
Das erste Problem ist das Mehl,
das ist ja die Basis von dem Kuchen.
Aber Mehl besteht
nicht nur aus Kohlenhydraten,
sondern auch aus Proteinen.
Darunter das "böse" Gluten,
für die, die es nicht vertragen.
Aber deswegen auch "böse",
weil es das Kleber-Protein ist,
das hatten wir auch schon
in dem Video über Plätzchen.
Das gibt dem ganzen
so ne gewisse Elastizität,
was wir beim Brot wollen, aber
bei so einem fluffigen Kuchen nicht.
Deswegen
habe ich hier sog. Kuchenmehl.
Das gibt es manchmal im Supermarkt
zu kaufen, steht dann extra drauf.
Das bedeutet, dass in Kuchenmehl
weniger Gluten drin ist
als z.B. in Brotmehl.
Die Butter ist erst mal
wichtig für den Geschmack.
Falls Ihr das letzte Video
mit den Plätzchen gesehen habt:
Seine Klebrigkeit entwickelt das
Gluten erst im Kontakt mit Wasser.
Butter ist hauptsächlich fett.
Und wenn Butter dann
auf diesen Mehlpartikeln draufliegt,
dann schirmt es das Mehl
ein bisschen vom Wasser ab.
Das bedeutet,
je mehr Butter drin ist,
desto weniger kann das Gluten
seine Klebrigkeit entfalten.
Hier haben wir
(sie lacht) ziemlich viel Zucker.
Es ist ein amerikanisches Rezept.
Zucker sorgt natürlich
erst mal für den süßen Geschmack.
Aber Zucker ist auch hygroskopisch,
das bedeutet, er zieht Wasser an.
Wenn wir also
den Zuckergehalt reduzieren,
wird der Kuchen
automatisch auch trockener.
Wenn der Kuchen
gleich in den Ofen kommt,
wird der Zucker
nochmal besonders wichtig.
Dann passieren zwei Sachen:
Erstens die Karamellisierung,
und zweitens die auf diesem Kanal
vielzitierte Maillard-Reaktion,
die die ganzen
leckeren Aromastoffe hervorbringt.
Wenn Ihr öfters backt,
werdet Ihr feststellen:
Viele Rezepte fangen damit an,
dass man die Butter
mit dem Zucker schaumig schlägt.
Das werden wir gleich auch machen.
Und zwar, um ganz viele Luftbläschen
rein zu bekommen, für den Fluff.
Zucker sind so kleine Kristalle,
die wirken wie kleine Schleifsteine,
die helfen beim Schlagen,
die Butter zu durchschneiden,
und so besser
die Luft rein zu kriegen.
Dann haben wir natürlich Eier, die
sind auch ganz wichtig beim Backen.
Das hatten wir schon
bei den Plätzchen:
in den Eiern sind Proteine drin.
Die sind am Anfang
noch so zusammengeknäult.
Im Ofen entknäulen sie sich,
verwirren sich zu nem Netzwerk,
und bringen so
die ganze Struktur in den Kuchen.
In diesem Rezept
haben wir drei Eier,
und dann nochmal drei Eigelb.
Eigelb hat mehr Fett,
Eiweiß hat mehr Wasser.
Das Fett hat dann so ne ähnliche
Funktion wie bei der Butter.
Und das Wasser dehnt sich
natürlich in dem Ofen nochmal aus.
Der Kuchen geht auf,
und wir kriegen noch mehr Fluff.
Das wichtigste für den Fluff
ist Backpulver, bzw. Natron.
Haben wir hier beides.
Backpulver und Natron
sind nicht dasselbe.
In englischen Rezepten
ist das "Baking Powder"
und das hier "Baking Soda".
Natron, also "Baking Soda",
ist Natriumhydrogencarbonat.
Wenn das mit Säure reagiert,
entstehen CO2-Bläschen,
und der Kuchen geht auf.
Hier haben wir Buttermilch.
Buttermilch ist sauer,
d.h. wenn Natron mit
Buttermilch reagiert, entsteht CO2.
Andere saure Sachen,
die man oft beim Backen verwendet:
Schokolade z.B. ist sauer, Kakao,
was noch - Joghurt.
Das allein
reicht aber nicht als Fluff,
deswegen haben wir nochmal
extra Backpulver dabei.
Backpulver
ist quasi Natron plus Säure.
Die Säure ist hier schon mit drin,
damit das
direkt reagiert und aufgeht.
Dann haben wir noch
ein bisschen Salz,
das ist auch für den Geschmack,
und ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt.
Ich hab mir Verstärkung geholt.
Das ist Christine.
Sie ist auch Chemikerin.
Denn zwei Chemikerinnen
sind besser als eine.
Ich würde sagen, wir legen los.
* Musik *
Das Rezept ist für 20 cm,
was hast du gesagt? - 20 cm.
20 wären bis hier,
das ist schon einiges...
Ich hätte lieber was über.
Nicht dass es dann zu flach ist,
und dann können wir keine
schöne Torte mehr draus machen.
Oh, warte mal,
ich habe noch so eine!
* Musik *
Guckt euch das an.
Der kann was, Leute, der kann was!
Der Kuchen...
Boah, das Frosting ist saugeil.
Das Rezept gibt es
unten in der Infobox,
mit allen anderen Infos
die Ihr brauchen könntet.
Wenn Ihr diesen Kuchen z.B. eurer
Mama zum Muttertag backen wollt,
könnt Ihr das gerne tun.
Wenn Ihr einfach mal
5 Minuten Zeit überhabt,
könnt Ihr in kürzester Zeit
diesen Kuchen herstellen.
Ja - schön schlau!
Das war Schönschlau.
Abonnieren nicht vergessen!